let's face it nobody is ever going to
call batman well-adjusted he dresses up
like a rodent and fights crime he hangs
out in a cave with an old man and a
rotating bunch of kids he picks fights
with superman
oh and he's got a serious ego problem
too everything has to be a batmobile a
bad plane or a bat signal even his dog
is a bat hound and not say just a
regular dog still there's a difference
between charmingly eccentric and
outright crazy and every now and then
batman crosses that line here are some
of the most terrible things batman's
ever done
oh
are you here
he left a villain to starve the late 80s
villain the kg beast has become a fan
favorite thanks to his ridiculous name
and delightfully dated cold war gimmick
but his first appearance ends in one of
batman's all-time cruelest acts in
batman number 420 kg beast attempts to
assassinate president reagan so batman
chases him through gotham sewers
clobbers him with a soggy corpse he
finds there which seriously raises
questions about gotham's toilets and
herds the beast into an empty room when
kgb sees that he's cornered he turns and
challenges batman to a fight but batman
just closes the door and blocks it off
making it impossible to open leaving kg
beast to die in a rat infested tomb
justifying his actions batman thinks i'm
not in this business to protect the
rules i serve justice it's just too bad
that the rule that batman is breaking is
the one about you know not killing
people even later writers were horrified
to make him less of a murderous maniac
eventually they wrote a story where
batman revealed that he'd actually
called the cops after trapping the beast
who managed to escape anyhow he
re-orphaned robin you could argue that
subjecting troubled teens to dangerous
training exercises and then sending them
out to fight psychopaths is terrible all
on its own and well you wouldn't be
wrong yet that's hardly the worst thing
batman has done to his robins for
example in the silver age comic book
world's finest number 153 build on the
cover as an imaginary novel as though
all the other comic books actually
happened bruce wayne becomes convinced
that superboy killed his parents and
plots his revenge against the last son
of krypton when robin protests batman
slaps him so viciously that the smack
traveled through time and became an
internet meme in the future when robin
won't relent batman sits him in a chair
and uses a villain's hypnosis machine to
erase all of dick grayson's memories
before dropping him off at an orphanage
so he won't get in the way of course
superboy didn't kill the wanes and a
guilt-stricken batman sacrifices his
life to save superman but nobody tells
robin who presumably languishes in the
orphanage until he's old enough to live
on his own and become an accountant or
something even in the regular comic
continuity robins get a raw deal batman
doesn't intervene in time when robin
number two jason todd is beaten half to
death with a crowbar by the joker and
then kills in an explosion later batman
admits jason was too young and impulsive
to be robin but that didn't stop bruce
from slapping a mask on him anyway it
happened again in 2013 when an assassin
killed the fifth robin damien wayne
you'd think that a smart guy like batman
could get it together but it actually
gets worse
he got robin's girlfriend killed in 2004
the third robin tim drake hung up his
cape after his father discovered his
secret identity in robin number 126
stephanie brown robin's long-term
girlfriend and a vigilante herself sews
her own robin costume and sneaks into
the bat cave hoping to gank tim's old
gig batman hires her on the spot not
because stephanie's qualified for the
position or anything but so he can make
tim jealous stephanie does the best she
can but her career as robin ends just
two issues later when batman fires her
for disobeying orders in order to earn
back batman's trust stephanie sets one
of bruce's top secret agendas into
motion starting a gang war that's
supposed to unite all of gotham's
criminals under the control of matches
malone one of batman's undercover
aliases it doesn't work and violence
consumes the city for her mistakes
stephanie is captured by the black mask
one of gotham's gang leaders and fatally
tortured all for the love of batman he
became a drug addict on purpose what
happens when batman can't get the job
done he resorts to substance abuse in
legends of the dark knight number 16 a
young girl drowns when batman can't lift
a boulder that traps her in a flooded
tunnel he decides he isn't strong enough
and when a few extra hours of crossfit
don't cut it he starts taking steroids
to enhance his strength the problem
other than the fact that drugs are you
know usually kind of terrible is that
the stuff batman takes is the same junk
that gives bane his super strength and
that doesn't always end well
batman juices himself enough to throw a
refrigerator through a brick wall but he
also develops a nasty mean streak once
batman is totally addicted the scientist
providing him with venom says that he'll
need to kill commissioner gordon if he
wants any more pills gordon lives
obviously and alfred locks batman in the
bat cave for a month while he detoxes
using sheer bat willpower and the power
of the bat beard now recovered batman
eventually tracks down the scientist to
shut the operation down no drugs
required and arrest him fair and square
he sent a guy to die in space lord death
man as the name kind of implies always
comes back from the dead batman and
robin once again triumphed over their
arch enemy lord death man after he
returned from the grave given that
batman doesn't usually kill that
shouldn't be a problem most of the time
he just locks his villain away in arkham
asylum and prays they won't get out but
for some reason batman decides to deal
with lord deathman in a much more
permanent manner in batman incorporated
number two he seals the villain in a
rocket and launches him into space where
he'll spend the rest of time completely
alone lord deathman's casually cruel
fate is made especially weird in the
comics final panels when bruce wayne and
selena kyle calmly share a drink while
lord deathman's ship twinkles in the sky
above beginning its long journey towards
absolutely nowhere or until it runs into
one of the billions and billions of
aliens that populate the dc universe
which it does
nice job batman he made plans to kill
his teammates jla's tower of babel arc
shows what happens when a supervillain
discovers batman's plans for beating his
justice league teammates and the results
aren't pretty after some bad guys
temporarily switch bodies with the
justice league batman decides to keep
detailed files about every league member
including ways to bring them down
unfortunately those files fall into the
hands of ra's al ghul who promptly uses
them in a bid to take over the world
things go bad pretty quickly aquaman
receives a custom dose of the
scarecrow's fear gas making him
terrified of water which he needs to
survive hypnotic suggestion blinds green
lantern robbing him of the ability to
control his power ring superman's skin
turns translucent thanks to some red
kryptonite which kicks his solar
receptors into overdrive causing
unimaginable pain a custom-made bullet
gives flash paralyzing seizures
understandably everyone gets pretty mad
at all batman they hold a vote about
keeping him on the team and batman just
cuts out before they get to make the
choice if you people can't see the
potential danger of an out of control
justice league i don't need to wait for
a vote
i don't belong here
he punks out batman needs gotham city
and gotham city needs batman just look
at what happens when he's not around in
batman beyond the dark knight hangs up
the cape and cowell after having a heart
attack mid-fight and being forced to aim
a gun at a criminal to prevent his death
decades after bruce wayne's retirement
from the nightlife gotham city falls
into the hands of a clown-themed street
gang called the jokers fortunately
amanda waller made a secret contingency
plan for the caped crusader ensuring
that a new younger hero would inherit
the mantle of batman and then there's
the dark knight returns frank miller's
infamous take on batman's ultimate
future batman gives up after jason
todd's death and in his absence a gang
called the mutants transformed gotham
city into a war-torn dystopia with old
man bruce brooding in wayne manor for a
decade superman becomes a pawn of the
government superhero dumb gets outlawed
and as expected crime is on the rise
everywhere you know who could have
stopped all this from happening
batman bruce wayne dedicated his life to
keeping gotham city safe and spent years
protecting the city it's hardly a
surprise that gotham came to rely on him
it's even arguable that batman's
presence in gotham entices super
villains looking for a challenge
suddenly disappearing isn't just
irresponsible retiring is quite
literally the worst thing that batman
could possibly do well retiring or doing
more of this in public
[Music]
for a guy whose job description is
literally crime fighter batman sure does
spend an awful lot of time fighting
other heroes you'd think having an
entire asylum full of homicidal clowns
living refrigerators and the occasional
immortal bioterrorist would keep him
busy enough but no every now and then
some well-meaning do-gooder gets in his
way and it's on batman has a pretty
strong track record against his fellow
heroes here are just a few who have felt
the wrath of the bat
superman historically speaking batman
and superman have been best friends and
the world's finest crime fighting team
since they met in the mid 40s they share
a mutual desire to devote their lives to
helping others but like all friends they
occasionally have their disagreements
we're willing to bet that most arguments
between pals don't usually devolve into
one person using a radioactive space
rock to poison the other but these guys
don't really seem like the calm
unreasonable types the two heroes most
famously came to blows at the climax of
the dark knight returns in which an
aging post-retirement batman enlists the
help of green arrow robin and the
entirety of gotham city's power grid to
have a fistfight so brutal that he ended
up giving himself a heart attack their
arguments aren't limited to
non-canonical alternate futures either
take a look at hush which is essentially
batman's greatest hits wrapped around
one of comics most ludicrously
convoluted mysteries we see superman's
mind taken over by poison ivy which
leads batman to put on a kryptonite ring
and uppercut superman back into his
right mind it's worth noting that both
of those fights involved superman
holding back but hey a victory with an
asterisk is still a victory
green lantern then we have the highly
controversial all-star batman and robin
the boy wonder it's so controversial
that you're probably familiar with it
even if you don't read comics batman
cutting at dick grayson in the batmobile
wonder woman calling a random pedestrian
a sperm bank batman and black canary
getting turned on by ultra violence it
all happens in this one story and you
can trust us context doesn't really make
it better batman's scene with green
lantern however is one of those rare
moments where something is so ridiculous
that it loops back around to being
amazing in order to face hal jordan
whose green lantern ring can't affect
anything yellow batman lures him into a
room where he has painted literally
everything yellow the furniture his
costume he's even spray painted his own
face and to top it all off he even
taunts and sneers at green lantern while
sipping on a refreshing glass of
lemonade until he finally baits him into
a physical confrontation of course it's
actually robin who does the fighting but
considering that batman's the one who
orchestrated the entire situation so
that a grown-ass superhero could get his
throat crushed by a ten-year-old
slathered in spray paint it's fair to
say the wind belongs to him
guy gardner batman's lantern problems
are nothing new coming at you from
1987's justice league number five batman
landed the single most famous hero vs
hero punch in the history of the dc
universe and possibly all of comic
history on one side you have guy gardner
the bowl cut green lantern commonly
known as the biggest jerk in the dc
universe constantly running his mouth
about how he should be running the team
on the other side we have batman at this
point you probably know what happens
next the conflict builds for a few
issues until finally guy re is back to
take a swing and batman drops him with a
single punch directly to the nose
knocking him out cold gaia's hit so hard
that the punch crossed realities into
the brave and the bold animated series
you so much as sneeze without my
permission you're going to regret it
that i'd like to see
one punch
one
and the best part guy remains
unconscious on the floor of the justice
league's kitchen until halfway through
the next issue while the rest of the
team goes on a mission then knocks
himself back out by hitting his head on
the underside of a counter as soon as he
wakes up in other words batman punched
him so hard and knocked him out twice
wildcat it's a tale as old as time
boxing champ ted grant was inspired by a
green lantern comic book and decided to
dress up as a six-foot kitty cat and
punch criminals until crime wasn't a
thing anymore listen it was 1941. nobody
really knew what they were doing back
then wildcat has traditionally been
shown as one of the fighters that
trained bruce wayne in the art of combat
during his teenage years but in brave
and the bold the joker was able to force
them to fight each other how by
threatening to shoot a puppy ultimately
they knocked each other out at the same
time listen it was 1975. they definitely
knew what they were doing but that
doesn't mean they didn't get weird with
it and if it's good enough for national
lampoon it's good enough for the joker
punisher while they're both on the same
side in the broadest way possible the
punisher's tendency to leave his
opponents as bullet-riddled corpses
clashes with batman's time-tested code
against killing and that comes to a head
when batman stops to punish her from
killing the joker during punisher slash
batman and deadly knights before batman
can explain that this is probably why
the punisher doesn't have a lot of
recurring villains frank castle decks
him with a hard right and batman in
classic fashion tells him he let him
have one punch because he knows he's
frustrated when punisher takes a second
swing however batman doesn't just catch
his fist he casually throws him face
first into a wall with a blunt i said
one
captain america batman vs captain
america is one of the most perfect
matchups you could ask for the only
problem is settling on a winner and
while the odds would tend to favor the
super soldier over the world's greatest
detective that's not always how it works
out in 1996's dc versus marvel the
decision was left up to a vote by the
fans the result was a brawl that took
place in a sewer in which the heroes
fought each other to a standstill until
a sudden rush of water swamped cap and
gave batman the chance to bop him over
the head with a batarang it's not
exactly the most dignified ending to a
fight but hey a victory with a
technicality is still a victory
interestingly enough when the two
characters squared off again for 2003's
jla slash avengers batman conceded that
while captain america could beat him in
a straight-up fight nobody had time for
all that ain't nobody got time for that
which when you think about it is a
pretty great way to weasel your way out
of a rematch teenage mutant ninja
turtles the weirdest thing about the
batman teenage mutant ninja turtles
crossover is that it somehow didn't
happen in 1990. it wasn't until 2015
that they actually met up but when they
did it was pretty much everything you
wanted to see dimension hopping
adventure shredder pitted against rao's
algol and mr freeze transformed into a
mutant polar bear which is pretty
amazing and of course it also gives you
a hero vs hero fight just to start
things off and unlike most of these this
one actually makes a lot of sense if
you're batman and you see a bunch of
five-foot turtles with ninja weapons
running around town everything that's
happened over the past 75 years is going
to lead you to the conclusion that
they're probably up to no good batman
not only takes out each of the four
ninja turtles in turn and fights
splinter to a draw before the turtles
have to retreat he also takes their
weapons and uses raphael's side to
shatter leonardo's katana in the end the
turtles pretty much become batman's
biggest fans give me the camera
well look he's doing his batman voice
hulk it's the most improbable victory of
all time and it happened in 1981's
batman vs the incredible hulk for the
most part it's a pretty fantastic fight
putting batman on the defensive against
hulk's unstoppable physical force it
even includes awesome moments like a
batman busting out a jackie chan style
dodge by leaping straight through the
open windows of a hulk hulled car as it
smashes against a wall the end of their
first encounter though has one of the
biggest bits of belief stretching since
captain america was swamped by sewer
water after realizing that punching
isn't going to get anywhere batman
simply drops some knockout gas and then
delivers a kick to the solar plexus so
hard that the hulk is forced to take a
deep inhale of that sweet sleepy cloud
hulk hits the floor and batman
celebrates a victory that probably never
should have happened
[Music]
batman is often treated like a god among
mortal superheroes by dedicated comic
fans after all he's basically a genius
ninja detective billionaire with enough
money to build weapons designed to beat
the most powerful heroes and villains in
the dc universe still comics writers
like to remind readers that batman is
totally capable of having his bat butt
kicked up and down the streets of gotham
even though he always bounces back let's
take a look at some of the heroes and
villains that have destroyed batman
bane
let's start with the obvious one the big
bad guy that beat batman so badly it
made the evening news in the summer of
1993 dc kicked off a major batman event
called nightfall in which batman becomes
burnt out after bane releases all of his
greatest villains from arkham asylum at
once while bats is overworked and
overstressed bane discovers that the
dark knight is bruce wayne which leads
to a violent showdown in the bat cave
things don't go well for batman bane
dominates the fight against a weakened
caped crusader he lifts batman over his
head and brings him crashing down over
his knee breaking batman's back and
putting him completely out of commission
it's become such an iconic takedown that
it made its way to the big screen in the
dark knight rises
all your money
it really is the most devastating hit
that batman has ever taken but it's not
the only one
superman
even within the ridiculous medium of
comics where anything is possible it
takes a lot to believe batman has a
realistic shot at defeating superman in
a one-on-one fight but somehow batman
often seems to come out on top often but
not always there was the time villain
maxwell lord made superman hallucinate
that he was battling darkseid in a
gladiatorial arena when in reality he
was beating on batman so badly that
bruce ended up in a coma in the story
lex luthor man of steel batman is
planning to attack superman with
kryptonite only to have soup literally
blow the rock out of batman's hand then
pound batman to within an inch of his
life again or how about the time an
alien parasite called blackrock took
over batman's body granting him
superhuman strength flight and a whole
lot of crazy even fighting a batman with
superpowers superman was able to punch
the parasite right out of his body by
the way punching is typically not a good
solution for dealing with parasites
wonder woman
in the 2016 graphic novel wonder woman
the hecatea batman is on the hunt for a
woman responsible for the deaths of sex
laborers and drug dealers in gotham and
she just so happens to be the very same
person wonder woman has been honor bound
to protect when the two titans of the dc
universe collide things get ugly mostly
for batman diana beats him into
submission and stands with a foot on his
head if that isn't the ultimate symbol
of batman getting owned we don't know
what is he escapes by invoking an
amazonian ritual but it's a pretty close
call prometheus
though he's a villain you don't hear
much about oh no
promotions prometheus prometheus is
batman's twisted mirror image and in an
even more literal way than joker or
two-face batman's family was gunned down
by a street thug but prometheus's
parents were criminals killed by the
police leading him to swear vengeance
upon those who attempt to bring justice
to the world like batman he's a trained
fighter he's filthy rich and he's got a
sharp mind but despite sharing the same
name he has very little to do with the
prometheus who makes an appearance in
the era verse prometheus masquerades as
the hero retro and walks straight into
the justice league's watchtower with a
helmet that grants him the skills of the
30 greatest martial artists in the world
including batman he then beats the snot
out of everyone and his trouncing of the
justice league only ends when catwoman
whips him in the nethers
deacon blackfyre
the cult is one of the darkest most
brutal stories in the batman canon
thanks to the vicious deacon blackfyre
leader of a cult of gotham's homeless
who've been brainwashed into doing his
murderous bidding during his
investigation into the cult batman is
captured by deacon's forces and spends a
huge chunk of the tale being tortured
and kissed gently on the cheek while
high on psychotropic drugs it's all an
attempt to brainwash batman into
fighting for blackfyre's underground
army batman's eventually saved by robin
but not before being reduced to a
sobbing husk of his former self and
having his entire worldview shattered
the best part robin finally gets batman
back for all those meme friendly slaps
to the face blackfyre isn't even the
only opponent to use drugs to take down
batman either
swamp thing you might think that swamp
thing is a joke and if you've ever heard
his old cartoon theme song you wouldn't
be wrong
[Music]
bad cartoons aside swamp thing isn't
just one of the most fascinating
characters in all of the dc comics he's
also one of the most powerful in fact
he's won pretty much every fight he and
batman have gotten into when batman
chases killer croc into swamp things uh
swamp the big green guy takes out bats
with a puff of hallucinogenic pollen the
most memorable beat down happened in
swamp thing number 53 when the muckman's
wife is in police custody and he
responds by turning gotham into a jungle
when batman confronts him swampy divides
himself into many swamp things and just
beats the snot out of batman like it's a
gang initiation ritual poor batman never
had a bat chance
deathstroke
slade wilson is one of the deadliest
characters in any comic book universe
regardless of the publisher he was the
world's greatest killer even before the
government experimented on him making
him even deadlier one of his first
fights after getting his own comic book
in the early 90s was with batman at this
point the dark knight was already
something of a legend able to defeat any
foe that crossed his path so it was kind
of a big deal when deathstroke and
batman threw down in an old school fist
fight and deathstroke beat him into
unconsciousness by tossing him into a
bookshelf the only reason batman is
alive today is because deathstroke
spared him and they ended up hanging
around together for a couple of issues
afterwards
lady shiva
the assassin known as lady shiva is one
of the greatest martial artists in the
world according to batman himself when
she's not an ally of batman she's
kicking his butt like in the pages of
nightwing number zero when shiva did
battle with both batman and dick grayson
at the same time she downed batman with
a poison tipped shuriken then beat up
dick until she felt sorry for him and
offered to train him he declined but it
was lady shiva's influence that
convinced dick grayson to stop being
robin and become his own man it was then
that he decided to become nightwing not
too many career decisions come from
watching someone beat up your dad but
hey comic books are weird
joker
crushing batman psychologically and
pushing him to the edge of his own
sanity is the joker's primary objective
and the list of joker's offenses is
disturbing and endless but the only time
that the joker has been able to
completely destroy batman was when he
stole the awesome power of an
interdimensional imp using the abilities
of superman antagonist mr mixie spitlick
joker warps reality to kill batman over
and over until superman makes him
realize that even though joker is
all-powerful he just can't bear to let
go of batman no you
you complete
me
darkseid
it's not surprising that someone like
darkseid who's basically a god can take
out a flesh and blood mortal like batman
what was surprising however was just how
darkseid did it during the final crisis
storyline it looked like darkseid simply
fried batman to a crisp with his weird
eye lasers of course no one really ever
stays dead in comic books for long as it
happened darkseid replaced batman's body
with a dead clone fooling superman and
most of his super friends and sent the
real batman traveling uncontrollably
through time why would he bother with
all of that because batman was turned
into a weapon whose forced time travel
adventures threatened to undo all of
reality eventually batman with a lot of
help from the justice league managed to
escape back to the present day without
destroying all of existence still the
important thing to keep in mind is that
he got his butt kicked and all it took
was a single glance holy spontaneous
combustion
[Music]
christopher nolan's epic batman series
ended on a somewhat confusing note
batman was essentially dead bruce wayne
retired in italy and all the villains
met a slow dramatic end but every
resolution seemed to bring yet another
cliffhanger so what exactly happened
with the finale of the dark knight rises
here's an explanation of what really
went down in the ending of nolan's
batman series and what it meant and
still could mean for the future
blast survivor
during the climax of the movie batman
scoops up the bomb threatening gotham
with his bat pod and the shoots off
toward the ocean as fast as he can where
it eventually explodes at a safe
distance from the city the now dead
batman is finally hailed as the hometown
hero he was all along and alfred heads
to florence likely holding on to a
sliver of hope that he'll find bruce
wayne living a new life as a quiet
family man just as he'd described at the
beginning of the film
of course alfred does spot bruce
lunching with selena kyle in a
pitch-perfect resolution that well seems
almost too good to be true and for many
viewers it was some fans interpreted
this as another instance of christopher
nolan's spinning top style trickery they
saw the scene of wayne's perfect
retirement as a part of alfred's
imagination but christian bale says what
we saw was what we got my personal
opinion is no it was not a dream
um that that was for real the fact that
lucia's fox later discovers that the
autopilot function on the bat had been
restored by bruce himself certainly lent
some credence to alfred's vision too the
light night rises
if batman was the dark knight then
officer john blake as the franchise as
robin is certainly a lighter shade of
justice you should use your full name i
like that name
robin
thanks
the orphan boy turned on his cop was a
champion of kids in need and helped
reconnect wayne enterprises with the
orphanage he'd grown up in he's also the
perfect person to take over and become
the city's newest masked hero in
batman's dead a future that was heavily
hinted at when he found the bat cave at
the end of the film we don't get to see
what his crime fighting style might be
like but based on its do gooder attitude
throughout the collapse of the city
blake could be an optimistic successor
to wayne's tenure as gotham's resident
hero so the movie's closing moments
where blake gets the key to the cave
asks the obvious question
room for a sequel it's been several
years since the dark knight rises closed
out nolan's batman trilogy but the
ending to the film definitely left the
door open to more exploration of his
grim vision of gotham city with blake
taking over the bat cave and plenty of
villains from the comics waiting for
their turn on screen there's a ton of
material to make this film series a
quadrilogy or even larger unfortunately
the would-be star of such a sequel
joseph gordon-levitt has cast doubt on
the idea of nolan's series ever getting
a fourth installment he told cinemablend
i think nolan very much thought of that
movie as a conclusion and there's a
theme that runs through all three of
these movies that begins in the first
movie runs through the second movie and
it concludes in that moment where he
says that batman is more than a man
batman is a symbol and so to have
another man other than bruce wayne kind
of becoming batman at the end of that
trilogy i think that's the perfect
ending to that story but still even if
nolan and gordon levitt aren't
interested in returning to the material
another filmmaker could in theory pick
up where nolan's series left off
somewhere down the line after all brian
singer's superman returns was a sequel
to superman 2 26 years later and singer
straight up ignored superman 3 and 4 so
never say never
setting a tone
before the dark knight the campiness of
1997's batman and robin derailed the
caped crusaders movie bank ability
hi frieze i'm batman
but the end of nolan's series signified
a major tonal shift giving us a much
more serious and dramatic style than the
previous set of batman
i'm
films
that new more grounded view of dc's
comic book characters would become
something of an inadvertent standard for
the dc expanded universe films to follow
just look at batman v superman dawn of
justice's grim gritty version of batman
the same dark tone coloured the palettes
of henry cavill superman and justice
league looks like it's heading in the
same direction and that's not the only
precedent nolan's film set for the
battle world either
the standalone series everyone knows
that shared comic book universes are all
the rage right now after all there's a
lot of money to be made by dangling one
piece of the shared universe as a must
see for the eventual superhero smash
film that's coming soon from each studio
even harry potter has gotten in on the
sequel prequel spin-off game but the
dark knight film proves that an endless
extension of a beloved property isn't
always necessary to rake in the big
books and earn respect at the same time
while sequel hopes might always loom
over nolan's trilogy it currently stands
alone as its own three-part series that
earned a lot of respect from critics and
had audiences forking over their cash at
the same time it's hard to imagine what
might have become of the series if nolan
had allowed warner brothers to spin the
franchise out into a shared universe of
its own but the fact is that he didn't
and his movie still accomplished
everything they meant to hopefully
future filmmakers will look back at his
trilogy and its standalone ending as the
perfect way to handle high profile
properties for the next generation
holy refreshing sense of humility batman
it sounds like christian bale really did
know when to say goodbye to his role as
a dark knight bale has been hot on the
publicity trail of late in support of
his new race car drama ford v ferrari in
which he plays a racer opposite matt
damon's mild-mannered car designer
recently the ford v ferrari press
campaign found the former batman actor
sitting down with the folks at the
toronto sun who used part of their time
with him to ask a question that's long
been on the minds of fans devoted to
bale's iconic work in christopher
nolan's dark knight trilogy the question
of course was this why didn't bale sign
on for a dark knight four braille's
answer to the question is as simple as
it is surprisingly humble the actor
claimed he ultimately decided a fourth
turn as the caped crusader would have
been quote over-indulgent that's right
in a time where stars and studios seem
to keep lining up blockbuster sequels to
milk every single penny out of a
franchise bale long regarded as a true
actors actor apparently told warner
brothers thanks but no thanks when the
studio approached him about reprising
his role as bruce wayne for another dark
knight venture and if bale is to be
believed he did so largely because he
didn't want to overstay his welcome and
the role more copycats last night alfred
with guns why don't you hide them and
take the weekend off that wasn't
exactly what i had in mind when i said i
wanted to inspire people
it's worth noting that bale's decision
was also greatly influenced by the fact
that nolan was indeed moving on from the
dark knight franchise as bale continued
to wax poetic about why he didn't return
for a fourth dark night flick he
admitted as much noting that outside of
his own wishes to leave batman behind
his decision to walk away from what
would have no doubt been a mammoth
payday for dark knight 4 was equally out
of respect for christopher nolan himself
bale explained we were never arrogant to
assume that we had an opportunity beyond
one film at a time that's something that
chris always would talk about he'd say
this is it we're making one film that's
all we've got then when they came and
said you want to go make another it was
fantastic but we still said this is it
we will not get another opportunity bail
went on to offer that while the trilogy
was far from a given for nolan's dark
knight saga it was if only indirectly
what the director had in mind from the
start the actor shared chris had always
said to me that if we were fortunate to
be able to make three we would stop
let's walk away after that then when
they warner brothers inevitably came to
us and said how about a number four i
said no we have to stick to chris's
dream which was always to hopefully do a
trilogy let's not stretch too far and
become overindulgent and go for a fourth
as we all know bale and nolan got two
more chapters of the gotham set saga
after the success of 2005's batman
begins with 2008's game changing the
dark knight and 2011's trilogy capping
the dark knight writers they also happen
to fashion one of the most celebrated
superhero trilogies in the history of
cinema
batman first hit the silver screen in
1943 and in the decades since he's been
one of hollywood's most accomplished
heroes in a dozen feature films we've
seen a truly incredible roster of caped
crusaders and dark knights taking the
character in plenty of different
directions as prominent as he's been in
film though not all batman are created
equal here's our ranking of every movie
batman from worst to best
batman 1943 the thing you really have to
understand about the original batman
serial is that it's bad even by the
standards of the time with 15 parts it's
three and a half hours of the worst
version of batman to ever hit the silver
screen batman and robin played by lewis
wilson and douglas croft a recast here
as government agents tasked with
stopping the villainous dr dhaka from
building a death ray and creating an
army of zombies i have converted him
into a zombie he can only act as i
direct
that might sound exciting but it's
atrocious and repetitive with awful
special effects hilariously awkward
costumes unconvincing fights and let's
not forget america was at war with japan
at the time so they played up the
japanese bad guy as you'd expect this
batman is definitely best left forgotten
batman and robin 1949 the only good
thing you can say about the second
batman serial is that it's not as
offensive as its predecessor it's still
bad though
the bumbling barely present batman is
trapped in an awful plot that stretches
out even longer than the first cereal
with robert lowry's batman stumbling
from one goofy cliffhanger to the next
in an attempt to unmask a mad scientist
called the wizard after four hours
surprise he turns out to be exactly the
guy you thought he was the whole time
the worst part though is the costume a
straight-up sweatsuit capped off with an
ill-fitting cow that makes him look more
like floppy eared bunny rabbit man
batman forever 1995
in a movie that's soaked in lime green
neon and hot pink leopard print val
kilmer's betrayal of the caped crusader
is
well
the kindest way to put it would be
reserved kilmore only two years removed
from a charismatic scene-stealing turn
as doc holliday in tombstone drifts
through batman forever with the scene
presence of a cardboard cutout to be
fair there was a good reason for kilmer
to make that choice director joel
schumacher was clearly drawing his
inspiration from the 1966 television
show and with jim carrey and tommy lee
jones chewing their way through every
available bit of scenery replicating
adam west's stentorian straight man
probably seemed like the best way to go
fully interactive holographs
only a high frequency carrier wave
beamed directly into the brain could
create such images there are parts where
it works but when it comes to actually
being batman his adam west impression
just doesn't land it's especially rough
in his tepid romance with nicole kidman
as dr chase meridian the worst named
love interest in the franchise and what
a grand pursuit you must be
batman robin 1997 to say batman and
robin has a bad reputation is putting it
lightly it's commonly regarded as one of
the worst superhero movies of all time
with a bloated cast of villains and
sidekicks sprawling out into a plot that
starts off silly and ends up full on
ludicrous it's so bad that both joel
schumacher and george clooney have
apologized for it and it was credited
with nearly killing the franchise until
it returned with the darker direction
under christopher nolan
all right everyone
two
but as controversial as it might sound
clooney himself is not actually that bad
his effortless charm doesn't really work
for batman but it actually does work
pretty well for bruce wayne if you can
get past the toy friendly suits and
their marble statue anatomy clooney's
best work comes when he's out of the
costume sweeping around wayne manor and
dealing with alfred's not quite fatal
illness plus let's be real here even if
clooney was as bad as the movie's
reputation would lead you to believe
he'd still score bonus points for the
way he refers to dick grayson when he
gets mad she's infected us with some
sort of pheromone extract oh is that
what it is bruce i'm under some kind of
magic spell she wants to kill you dick
batman the superman dawn of justice and
justice league 2016-2017
much of director zack snyder's
inspiration for batman v superman came
from frank miller's landmark comic story
the dark knight returns unfortunately
while the movie definitely lifted entire
scenes wholesale from the comics in an
effort to please hardcore fans they're
all separated from the original context
ben affleck's batman is a ludicrously
violent murderer who is easily
manipulated into a fist fight with
another superhero which ends when the
person he's fighting reminds him that
other people also have
mobs why did you say that
it's his mother's name
despite the movie's silly plot
coincidences affleck's batman has some
noteworthy fight sequences even if by
this point the character apparently gave
up trying to uphold his no kill rule
the lego batman movie 2017 the lego
version of batman is the rarest kind of
satire a parody of something that
actually does a great job at being the
thing that it's parodying will arnett
voices batman as a full-on comedy
character he's got an obsession with
darkness and arnett ramps up his
naturally gravelly voice into a spoof of
christian bales at the same time though
he's very rarely presented as anything
other than extremely good at what he
does an ultra competent superhero who
really does act heroically most of the
time either way it works while other
portrayals might do their best to move
away from the inherent silliness of a
guy dressed as a bat who primarily
fights murder clowns embracing it gives
the lego version a flavor that helps him
rival even the best of his big screen
contemporaries as funny as he might be
he's still batman in one of his purest
forms
the dark knight trilogy 2005-2012
there's a moment in batman begins where
a crooked cop gets snared by the ankle
and hauled up five stories in the middle
of a thunderstorm so that a vigilante
who looks like satan himself can scream
in his face i don't know
i swear to god
so yeah when you're describing christian
bale's performance the word you want is
intense bale's batman brings that level
of intensity to everything he does
showing an emotional range that
stretches from the righteous fury of
batman to the aimless pain of the orphan
bruce wayne who has denied his vengeance
and even the quippy sarcasm of his
exchanges with alfred it's a powerful
portrayal that's only ever matched when
he goes up against heath ledger's joker
one of the best performances in the
genre batman batman returns
1989-1992 here's the thing about tim
burton's batman movies they're great
timber movies they have an incredible
visual style especially when it comes to
gotham city it's a hellish industrial
urban sprawl slammed against retro art
deco where everyone still dresses like
it's 1940 and where purple knockout gas
is a deadly threat against a
monochromatic cityscape they're full of
great bits of satire beautiful
cinematography and the casting is
amazingly obvious pitting our hero
against jack nicholson michelle pfeiffer
jack palance and christopher walken the
problem is that dc and warner brothers
were still trying to figure out what
batman and bruce wayne should be like in
the modern era the result was some
awkward exchanges between bruce wayne
and vicki vale as we see batman's human
side struggle no one really captures
that disconnect more than michael keaton
did when he put on the cape and cow he's
actually kind of perfect for the kind of
remote mysterious weirdo who sleeps
upside down because he wants to be more
like a bat now you want to get nuts come
on let's get nuts but there's a
difference between the stylized
goofiness the burton explored in movies
like pee-wee's big adventure and
beetlejuice and the 80s action movie
aesthetic that saw keaton's batman
blowing up buildings full of criminals
batman's actions are mostly portrayed as
a personal quest for vengeance that only
incidentally winds up saving a city and
that's a shame bruce wayne's borderline
psycho exchanges aside michael keaton
ultimately nails the dark almost
spectral version of batman that
terrifies most of gotham's criminals i
want you to tell all your friends about
me what are you
i'm
batman
the movie 1966
the best thing about adam west's
performance in batman 66 is that it can
mean completely different things
depending when you watch it as a child
it's easy to buy west's batman is
completely genuine and as an adult once
you're in on the joke the fact that he
was able to play the perfect straight
man for a wild cast of villains is every
bit as astonishing as those surface
level comic book thrills the movie
released on the big screen in 1966
between the first two seasons of the
show has everything in a literal sense
the arch villains this time around are
four of his greatest foes brought
together as the united underworld
revealed with a sequence in which batman
and robin identified their enemies
through profound leaps of logic you mean
where there's a fish there could be a
penguin but wait it happened at c
see
c for catwoman at the same time it's
easy to forget that west is actually
really good as batman particularly when
he goes to save his love interest miss
kitka the links he's willing to go and
the heartbreak in his eyes when he
discovers that she was catwoman all
along even if you're watching it with a
healthy level of irony it's a powerful
moment no actor has ever been as
strongly identified with the role of
batman as adam west and this movie shows
exactly why his performance walks a
delicate balance between full-hearted
adventure and witty satire and the end
result is perfect he is and always will
be the batman who won't even risk
hurting a bunch of baby ducks
some days you just can't get rid of a
bomb
batman mask of the phantasm 1993 okay
we'll admit that this one is a bit of a
cheat kevin conroy has after all been
the most prominent batman actor for more
than 25 years making his debut on batman
the animated series and staying in the
role all the way through the arkham
video games but there's a good reason
for that conroy is an amazing batman and
everything that makes him great is on
display in mask of the phantasm the film
is the first time that the animated
series really dug into batman's origin
story and conroy's performance sold it
beautifully the scene when he's pleading
with his parents graves telling them he
doesn't want to fight crime because he's
finally found happiness is devastatingly
emotional
i know i made a promise
but i didn't see this coming
i didn't count on being happy even
better is when that happiness is taken
away and bruce gives himself over to his
mission entirely for a generation of
batman fans conroys is the voice they
hear in their heads when they read
comics and that alone should show just
how great he was in the role it takes an
incredible amount of talent to redefine
the character but that's exactly what
kevin conroy did in a way that no other
batman
could the cape's crusaders ongoing film
saga ranks among the top five highest
grossing movie franchises in the united
states but he's also faced his share of
setbacks along the way for every bat
blockbuster that made its way to
theaters there's a take on the character
that's unceremoniously died in
development here's the history of every
one of those cancelled batman movies
the batman getting tim burton's 1989
batman onto the big screen was a
difficult process 10 years before
michael keaton made his dark knight
debut producers benjamin belnicker and
michael uslan acquired the film rights
to batman so they could adapt the
character in the same vein as superman
they wanted to have a definitive dark
version of batman on film and producers
john peters and peter goober agreed when
they boarded the project in november
1979. four years later the script by
james bond and superman screenplay
co-writer tom mankiewicz simply titled
the batman was completed focusing on
batman and robin's origins with the
joker as the central villain while the
batman double 07 version of that man
would have been awesome the project went
through multiple developers and
producers losing bits and pieces along
the way in the end the studio hired tim
burton to direct who felt the treatment
was too similar to superman and would be
a better fit for a tv series he changed
virtually every aspect of the movie so
while they didn't get everything they
wanted the producers still got their
darker version of batman on the silver
screen
it just took a decade to make it happen
robin spin-off when chris o'donnell
joined the franchise as robin for 1995's
batman forever he seemed poised for a
long run as the character he returned
for 1997's batman and robin and planned
to reprise his role in a possible fifth
film but that never came to fruition
warner brothers also briefly pursued a
robin spin-off which o'donnell confirmed
as recently as 2012 as he told access
hollywood they were going to do a robin
movie back in the day then batman and
robin was such a bomb they were like
scrap that that was the end of that
batman unchained joel schumacher told
variety that he'd always plan to make
three batman movies but unfortunately
for everyone involved in schumacher's
bat saga batman and robin tanked sending
the franchise into years of development
hell and leaving that third movie
unrealised the problems weren't just at
the box office however akiva goldsman
who wrote the screenplays for
schumacher's first two batflicks opted
not to return for the next installment i
am legend screenwriter mark protesovich
took goldman's place and came up with
the name batman unchained which focused
on scarecrow as the central villain
schumacher wanted nicolas cage to play
the fear-inducing bad guy saying that he
owed the world quote a real batman movie
but batman and robin crashed and burned
taking batman unchained with it changing
course completely warner brothers
started looking into the idea of making
up batman beyond all batman year one
film instead
batman dark knight writers lee shapiro
and stephen wise had an idea for a full
bat reboot this time instead of batman
and robin in their primes the duo wanted
to see batman retired with dick grayson
attending college in the proposed film
dr jonathan crane better known as the
scarecrow still played a prominent role
as a professor of psychology at gotham
university also appearing dr kirk
langstrom who turns into the monstrous
man bat the two doctors get into a
confrontation and crane accidentally
initiates kirk's transformation into his
bat like form after seeing man bat
terrorize gotham and that the city's
residents are mistaking him for the real
batman the dark knight comes out of
retirement to clear his name the darker
idea was pitched to the studio but after
being passed through multiple levels of
approval and a few confirmations from
producers the studio's director of
development passed on the movie
batman year one schumacher still wanted
to give batman fans a proper caped
crusader and his planned adaptation of
frank miller's batman year one might
have fulfilled that goal ultimately the
studio parted ways with schumacher and
went with requiem for a dream director
darren aronofsky instead after hiring
aronofsky the studio bolstered the
project's pedigree further by bringing
frank miller himself on board to script
in an interview with ign aronofsky urged
fans to quote toss out everything you
can imagine about batman everything
we're starting completely anew
unfortunately the studio didn't get into
miller's version of the script so they
hired the wachowskis of matrix fame to
write a treatment again the studio
wasn't satisfied so they turned to joss
whedon whose take also didn't pass
muster with the studio they finally
ended up shelving the idea all together
in 2002 batman beyond warner brothers
also floated the idea of making a batman
beyond film inspired by the hit animated
show which had debuted in 1999. bruce
tim and paul deeney's series featured
terry mcginnis a teenager who takes over
the mantle of batman under the guidance
of a retired bruce wayne the studio's
movie division liked batman beyond so
much that they wanted to make a live
action version for the big screen they
hired remember the titans director bohas
yaiken to helm the project with deeney
writing the script sources told variety
in 2000 that a batman beyond film didn't
interfere with warner brothers plans to
continue with a fifth batman movie but
that changed quickly by august 2001
deeney said that the studio had shelved
the live-action adaptation what's more
later that year the batman beyond
animated series was cancelled
batman vs superman asylum long before
zack snyder's batman vs superman dawn of
justice hit the big screens warner
brothers previously had plans to pit the
dc universe's two biggest heroes against
each other andrew kevin walker who
penned the incredibly dark seven pitched
an idea that involved batman coming out
of retirement shortly after his wife's
death to join a recently divorced
superman until of course they're duped
by lex luthor into fighting each other
sound familiar akiva goldsmith returning
to the franchise once more revised
walker's script in 2002 which was enough
to convince warner brothers to move
forward with the project
at least for a little while
wolfgang peterson director of air force
one and the never-ending story intended
to direct the film in 2003. part the
project was derailed when jj abrams
jumped into the fray with a script for a
movie called superman flyby which
included a very different version of the
man of steel according to peterson the
studio decided to try separate versions
of superman and batman instead resulting
in superman returns and batman begins
justice league mortal 2017's justice
league wasn't the first attempt to bring
batman and the rest of the league to the
big screen in 2009 the first plan to
bring dc's heroes together came awfully
close to hitting theaters written by
kieran and michelle mulroney justice
league mortal was to be helmed by mad
max director george miller its cast
included dj katrina as superman army
hammer as batman megan gale as wonder
woman adam brody as the flash common as
green lantern and teresa palmer as talia
al ghul with jay barochel playing the
villain maxwell lord cameras were ready
to roll but the writer strike of the
late 2000s put a damper on the movie the
overwhelming success of christopher
nolan's the dark knight convinced warner
brothers that a justice league with a
different batman simply wouldn't work
justice league mortal is the justice
league movie that never was so when
you're watching ben affleck throw down
with carl drogo just think about how
much crazier it would have been if the
director of mad max had gotten to the
league first
oh what a day
what a lovely day
unless you spent the last 80 years
living in a bat cave you probably
already know a whole lot about batman
his origins his fancy gadgets and his
penchant for young sidekicks what you
might not know is that an insane series
of events drove batman to being the dark
brooding vigilante that he is today here
are some of the craziest moments in
batman's history
zur and are
in the mid-1950s batman began to have
interdimensional and outer space
adventures instead of just fighting
street level thugs and weirdos so in
batman 113 our hero makes a strange trip
to visit a tattered multi-colored batman
from planet 0nr who needs earth's
batman's help fighting an alien invasion
though batman really should have just
arrested zeran r for his crimes against
fashion
you just booked your next vacation rotol
a luxurious stay on the set alpha nine
prison planet if this wasn't strange
enough modern batman writer grant
morrison included the formerly forgotten
insane adventure from batman's zany
comics history into being some kind of
trip into bruce wayne's personal
imagination land apparently batman
himself created zur nr batman as a
backup personality in case he ever went
insane because people can be backed up
like hard drives apparently
batmite
the following year in detective comics
number 267 batman is visited from the
fifth dimension by an all-powerful imp
named batmite who absolutely worships
the dark knight after all
i'm your number one fan
my fan
the biggest
batmite sets some increasingly strange
challenges so he can see his hero in
action including making an enormous
statue of batman himself come to life
naturally batman is annoyed by having
another little punk hanging around the
bat cave but the guy persists on and off
for the rest of batman's career what
is it
baby
batman endures dozens of unusual
transformations during the silver age
including periods of getting super old
turning into an ape and a tiger and
being a genie however a few changes are
so strange as batman 147's
transformation into a baby rather than
taking the afternoon off batman insists
on wearing some suspenders and
continuing to fight crime because if you
thought a man dressed as a bat was
terrifying a violent baby is truly the
stuff of nightmares like can you punch
it in self-defense or what
zebra batman
quick disclaimer as an englishman we say
zebra not zebra i was asked to record
this part saying zebra so just know that
every time i say zebra i'm dying inside
thank you for your time anyway zebra man
most cited batman's period of wearing
rainbow colored outfits as his strangest
but his time as a zebra patterns crime
fighter was even stranger after going up
against zebra man a guy in black and
white who can emit rays of magnetic
force batman and robin go to investigate
the criminal's lab because robin is a
darwin award waiting to happen he trips
and zaps batman with the same machine
that gave zebra man his powers also
giving him a similar suit in the process
as usual batman literally punches the
stripes off of zebra man and everything
returns to normal well relatively normal
death of robin
after the silver age ended the once
carefree batman of the 60s became darker
everything reached a boiling point by
1988 to death in the family the joker
kidnaps robin's estranged neglectful
mother beats robin nearly to death with
a crowbar and sets off a bomb readers at
home were given the chance to call a dc
comics hotline and let them know if they
thought robin should survive or go after
the bat cave in the sky and a slight
majority of overwhelmingly bitter nerds
decided that robin should bite the big
one robin dies and batman sets out on a
darker grimmer path from which he'll
never recover thanks geeks
killing joke
because the joker is on a mission to
destroy everything that batman loves he
goes on as much malicious and personal
crime spree in bad history in the
killing joke the clown prince of crime
shoots barbara gordon also known as
batgirl and paralyzes her permanently
before kidnapping her father
commissioner gordon the commissioner is
kept naked in a cage of circus freaks
and forced to look at images of his
daughter naked and in agony from a
gunshot wound batman's entire world
continues to fall apart and his real
insanity begins to show through
venom
after accidentally letting a little girl
drown batman starts to use a strength
enhancing drug called venom knowing that
it's a bad idea but willing to do
anything to prevent another death after
realizing that his addiction is sending
him into an irrational rage and doing
more harm than good batman locks himself
in the basement for a month and detoxes
by sheer willpower because damn he's
batman but a recovering batman is still
a sight to behold
nightfall
two years later a criminal named bane
gets a hold of the same drug that batman
was previously abusing and uses it to
enhance himself enough to snap batman's
spine
but only after releasing all of the
criminals in arkham to wear down the
caped crusader into a state of total
exhaustion batman remains paralyzed for
a while while the violent protege of his
takes over the batman name and causes
the wrong kind of chaos for gotham's
criminals totally messing up the batman
brand even worse on this guy
batman whets his pants
if there's a single moment in batman's
history that has no right to exist
including this
it's kevin smith's comic tale in which
batman wets his units are because he
stands too close to an explosion because
smith lives in a world where adults
regularly cannot control their bodily
functions smith drags the dark knight
into unforgivable territory he only
makes it worse by openly discussing
batman's bedroom habits and making
catwoman have a temper tantrum once she
learns that bruce is getting married bob
should have stayed silent on this one
zapped through time
batman's time travel adventures from the
silver age make a comeback when
supervillain darkseid shoots the hero
with his omega beams normally these
beams erase their victim from existence
but this time they send batman back to
the stone age where he lives as a
caveman for a while before slipping
through other eras in which he's a witch
hunter a pirate a cowboy and a 1930s
detective when bruce wayne eventually
stumbles back into present day after his
epic journey the justice league has to
stop his heart to prevent dangerous
omega energy from destroying the world
anyhow he survives because batman is the
most badass superhero
since he made his debut in batman issue
1 the joker has been the dark knight's
deadliest arch nemesis as the years went
on however his crimes went beyond
thematic robberies and into brutal
murders including clubbing robin to
death with a crowbar that raises a
question that's hard to ignore why
doesn't batman just kill him
it's pretty clear after all these
decades that putting a permanent end to
the joker would solve at least half of
gotham city's problems which makes it
difficult for plenty of readers to
suspend their disbelief if you really
want to know the actual definitive
answer though we've got it you just
might not like it that's because the
answer exists entirely in our world
where batman is a fictional character
designed to appear in movies tv shows
and at least four comic books every
month forever if batman kills the joker
we can't have any more joker stories he
is in very blunt and realistic terms too
popular to die and he's been that way
since the beginning from the first day
that jerry robinson drew him on the page
the contrast of the smiling murderer and
the scowling spooky hero made him
batman's perfect dutch enemy even by the
dawn of the silver age when batman
became a much brighter more super-heroic
character the joker remained one of the
most prominent villains all of which is
to say that joker stories sell they sell
a lot and on top of that he's an
interesting character that creators like
to make comics about as much as fans
like to read them unfortunately batman's
real world inability to kill the joker
has to be justified in the story and
that justification has become
exponentially more difficult over time
it's very easy to understand why batman
keeps taking the joker back to welcome
asylum when he's robbing banks and
committing gimmick crimes even if
there's an occasional murder thrown in
to keep him scary after all no one ever
asks why batman doesn't just drag the
riddler out back and shoot him by the
time we got to the 80s though as batman
himself was redefined for a new era the
joker was forced to become every bit as
unstoppable just on the other side
this was when he truly became batman's
opposite and if batman was going to be
the greatest hero in the world the joker
had to be the absolute worst villain
before the decade was out the joker went
from being an occasionally murderous
arch villain to the psychopath who shot
and assaulted barbara gordon tortured
her father killed robin and tried to
murder the entire united nations in fact
all that happened in one year by the end
of the 90s the joker was leaving a body
count in the double digits at minimum
every time he showed up and was pretty
consistently characterized as an
irredeemable monster when jason todd the
former robin that the joker crowbarred
to death came back to life in 2005 he
raised exactly these questions forcing
batman to provide an in-story reason for
why he can't ever kill his oldest
deadliest enemy in that story batman
told jason that if he ever killed the
joker he'd be unable to stop himself
from killing every other criminal who
got in his way and jason like plenty of
readers found that argument to be
incredibly frustrating can the world's
greatest detective really not tell the
difference between a guy who turned an
entire city into smiling zombies and led
a death parade through the streets from
like kite man
really when you get right down to it
though batman's attitude toward killing
the joker actually has an internal logic
and consistency it's not actually about
the joker it's about batman himself
while casual fans might attribute
batman's famous code against killing to
the interference of the comics code it
actually dates back to 1941 predating
the code by 13 years either way it
became a fundamental truth about the
character reinforcing the idea that
batman has his roots in reacting to
someone taking a life two lives if you
want to be technical about it that's the
tragedy that he defines himself in a
position too and the thing that he's
always trying to prevent death he's a
crime fighter and while he might fight
bank robbers when they're around the
taking of a life is the opposite of who
he is besides don't forget that batman
lives in a world where ghosts are 100
real if you thought the joker was
trouble when he was living you
absolutely do not want to know what
happens once he shows up in the
afterlife
after all these years it's easy to
assume we've learned everything there is
to know about director christopher
nolan's dark knight trilogy but just
like batman himself these movies are
very good at keeping their secrets
batman and superman are often presented
in stark opposition to one another one
is a dark figure who triumphs through
technology and intimidation the other is
a bright hero who triumphs through
superpowers and inspiration with that in
mind it might be surprising to hear that
christopher nolan's batman actually owes
quite a bit to the man of steel nolan
has said that like many people he was
blown away by richard donner's superman
the movie in 1978. among its many
brilliant features he appreciated that
it told the full story of superman's
origin nolan contrasted this with tim
burton's 1989 batman film in which the
character is fully formed by the time
the movie starts and saw batman begins
as his chance to do batman in the style
of superman 78 a movie where he could
start with a more recognizable setting
grounded in reality with a single
extraordinary figure in it and as the
title implies explore that hero's
beginnings while the shape of the
current slate of modern dc films comes
from the clash between batman and
superman nolan's masterful trilogy could
never have started without the
inspiration of the big blue boy scout
well i certainly hope this little
incident hasn't put you off flying miss
statistically speaking of course it's
still the safest way to travel
one of the most notable aspects of
nolan's dark knight trilogy is how much
christian bale made the character his
own he was after all the seventh actor
to don the costume for the big screen
going all the way back to the 40s and he
knew it was inevitable that he'd be
compared to previous batman all of which
makes it that much more fascinating that
when bale auditioned for the role of
batman he did so while wearing val
kilmer's old batman suit from batman
forever in fact nolan made every
prospective batman actor wear the old
suit why go through all the trouble
according to the director being batman
on screen transcended concepts such as
chemistry or simple acting ability
instead he needed an actor who would be
believable and compelling without being
overshadowed by the iconic imagery that
made batman who he is
or in other words he really just needed
a guy who looked good in the suit no
wonder bale did so many push-ups
without a doubt viewer's first glimpse
of harvey dent's burned face is
appropriately grisly
i'm sorry
[Music]
no
[Music]
no you're not
the amount of damage is horrifying and
it gives us a powerful glimpse of the
monster he's become as he dispenses his
brand of random coin-based justice
against those who've wronged him because
of how utterly gross two-face ended up
looking it's surprising to hear
christopher nolan admit that he was
originally going to be even more
repulsive in an interview nolan
characterized the final choice for two
faces appearance as one of the ones
least likely to disturb fans why is that
call it the uncanny valley effect
according to nolan they tried versions
that were a little less gory but they
wound up being too realistic and way too
disturbing he made the apt comparison to
the pirates of the caribbean movies
noting that the way the undead were
rendered in those films used a less
realistic more exaggerated style that
ultimately made the imagery quote more
powerful and less repulsive
in the dark knight heath ledger gave
such a powerful and singular performance
as the joker that it's still difficult
to imagine anyone else in the role even
after seeing joaquin phoenix's
compelling performance in joker
nonetheless even ledger's performance
had its precedence much of the dark
knight trilogy selectively draws from
comics lore and for the dark knight one
major element of the joker's plan is
taken from the killing joke by comics
legend alan moore and brian bolland
[Music]
that comic is infamous for a number of
reasons the joker paralyzes and assaults
barbara gordon and kidnaps commissioner
gordon taking him to a demented fun
house where he's tortured with images of
what the joker's done to his daughter
why do all this to break batman's most
dedicated ally proving that everyone is
only one disastrously bad day away from
becoming as twisted as he is sound
familiar it should in dark knight
ledger's joker gives two boats one
filled with average citizens and one
filled with prisoners with the capacity
to blow each other up he gambles that
the so-called regular people will give
in to their base impulses and kill
dozens of people to save themselves in
both cases though he's proven wrong in
the comics gordon retains his sanity and
the citizens and prisoners of the movie
don't descend into becoming killers
another comic book series that heavily
contributes to the dark knight is jeff
loeb and tim sales 1996 miniseries
batman the long halloween a story that
unfolds over the course of a year early
in batman's career batman james gordon
and a as yet unscarred harvey dent form
an alliance to take down gotham's
organized crime the first issue ends on
halloween night when batman and dent
find where the mob's secret cash storage
is and burn it all to a crisp a scene
that gets a nod in the dark knight when
the joker burns huge stacks of cash in
the belly of a ship by the end of the
mini-series it's clear a new kind of
criminal has risen in gotham to replace
the mob in the final issue almost all of
batman's more well-known villains unite
in a final assault on mob boss sal
moroney's home it's two-face who
eventually kills moroni just as he does
in the dark knight we hear echoes of
this shift from mobster to super villain
in the dark knight particularly during
the interrogation scene when joker talks
about how batman has changed gotham but
i know the truth there's no going back
you've changed things
forever it's implied in both the movie
and in the long halloween that it's
batman's very existence that leads to
this escalation but the main inspiration
comes in how both the movie and the
comic chronicled the fall of the
idealistic harvey dent and the birth of
two-face
christopher nolan and his brother
jonathan who co-wrote the dark knight
rises admitted to drawing inspiration
from a seemingly unlikely source charles
dickens classic a tale of two cities in
retrospect though it seems a bit obvious
at the end commissioner gordon even
reads from the book at bruce wayne's
funeral it is a far
far better thing that i do
than i have ever done
in a tale of two cities one man about to
be executed charles darnay is saved when
his identical double sidney carton takes
his place but not before carton waxes
philosophic about the beautiful city and
brilliant people who are rising from the
abyss sounds a little familiar right the
one big difference is that the death in
the film ends up being more symbolic as
it's batman who dies so bruce wayne can
lead a happy normal life
in addition to drawing from dickens the
dark knight rises mashes up several
different comic story lines it borrows
one basic concept from the dark knight
returns in which an aging bruce wayne
comes out of retirement to deal with a
gotham that's only gotten worse in his
absence while bruce wayne isn't eligible
for the senior citizen discount in this
movie the earlier narrative does make a
big deal of what it's like for wayne to
return to the role of a hero after eight
years of retirement the movie also
brings in elements of nightfall the
story arc in which bane discovered who
batman really was and after weakening
him by unleashing arkham asylum's
inmates on the city broke into wayne
manor and broke his back in the comics
batman was out of commission for quite a
while with caped crusader duties being
taken over by the unstable character of
azrael the final comic inspiration was
no man's land a story that saw gotham
city impacted by an enormous earthquake
in response the government and one can
only assume they were just waiting for a
chance to do something like this
destroyed all bridges into gotham and
prevented other access to it declaring
the entire city a no man's land citizens
can't get out and the villains decide to
take over the movie inverts this of
course with thane and his crew cutting
the city off but the narrative of trying
to survive in isolation and surrounded
by psychopaths remains
it's tough at this point to imagine
batman without nolan's trilogy however
before he brought the world into focus
with batman begins there were a number
of false starts while warner brothers
spent a decade trying to figure out
where they wanted to take the franchise
an explicit live-action adaptation of
the dark knight returns was scrapped and
batman year 1 was nearly adapted twice
amusingly one of these scrapped movies
included batman vs superman which very
nearly came out in 2004 perhaps the
weirdest movie planned was the studio's
second attempt at a batman year one
adaptation it would have been directed
by darren aronofsky famous for movies
such as requiem for a dream with a
screenplay by aronofsky and batman year
one comic writer frank miller in the
story bruce wayne is a poor kid taken in
and raised by a mechanic on the wrong
side of the tracks he becomes an
unhinged vigilante in the style of taxi
drivers travis bickle later in
inspiration for 2019's joker the story
was also set to feature an unhinged
violent and somewhat suicidal jim gordon
fortunately the project was axed paving
the way for our familiar dark knight
trilogy to unfold
months before ledger's death christian
bale praised his co-star's commitment to
his role during an interview referencing
the scene when batman confronts joker in
the gcpd interrogation room bale told
thr that heath ledger insisted that he
hit him for real
never start with the head the victim
gets all fuzzy apparently the physical
punishment didn't end with the beating
ledger took bale went on to describe
ledger quote
slamming himself around and there were
tiled walls inside of that set which
were cracked and dented from him hurling
himself into them
throughout the dark knight trilogy the
most noticeable casting change is bruce
wayne's old friend and love interest
rachel dawes created specifically for
the film trilogy and not appearing in
the comics dawes is played by katie
holmes and batman begins but is replaced
by maggie gyllenhaal in the dark knight
the change led to speculation that
holmes whose performance wasn't met with
the most enthusiastic reviews was the
victim of harsh critics christopher
nolan denied this saying home simply was
not available for the dark knight it
took eight years but holmes finally
broke her silence about it to confirm
her absence in the dark knight was her
own choice and went on to praise
gyllenhaal for doing quote a wonderful
job she didn't explain her reasons for
leaving the franchise though maybe she
just didn't want to be blown up by an
evil clown as for gyllenhaal she wanted
to be sure that it was holmes decision
too she reportedly reached out to ask
for holmes blessing before giving a firm
yes to replacing her as rachel dawes
christopher nolan is known for going to
great lengths to keep plot points of his
film secret and the dark knight trilogy
was no exception how does nolan achieve
this level of secrecy well apparently he
tells his actors the bare minimum they
need to know ask liam neeson he tapped
neeson to reprise his role as raz al
ghul for a cameo in 2012's dark knight
rises and apparently told the actor
absolutely nothing about the film he
later said in an interview that it
wasn't that he didn't want to discuss
the plot but that he couldn't because he
literally didn't know anything about it
neeson may have only had a small part in
dark knight rises but as the butler
alfred pennyworth michael kane was a
significant part of batman begins and he
got similar treatment when asked to
appear kane said that nolan appeared at
his door personally with the draft for
batman begins and asked if he was
interested in playing alfred nolan just
sat there while kane read the script and
then took it with him when he left
over the years a handful of actors have
given us memorable performances as
alfred pennyworth but while tastes will
always differ you'd have a rough time
arguing that anyone has done a better
job of embodying alfred than michael
caine the actor gave us an alfred who
would go to any length to support bruce
wayne's efforts to save gotham while at
the same time desperately wanting
nothing more than for wayne to give up
the cowl and cape so he can find some
true commitment surprisingly it came
close to not happening in fact kane has
admitted that when he was initially
approached about the role as alfred he
was not at all enthused saying quote i
thought that wasn't a very good part
i'll be saying dinner is served and
would you like a coffee presumably kane
was thinking of previous versions of the
character like the late michael goff of
the tim burton joel schumacher films
whose portrayal of the character showed
no signs of ever hunting jewel thieves
in the jungles of burma can i persuade
you to take a sandwich with you sir
i'll get drive through
thankfully kane learned nolan had bigger
plans for his character although his
early hesitation became a running joke
between him and nolan he told the
huffington post that in 2011 nolan sent
him a christmas present a dinner gong
with dinner is served engraved on it
one enduring superhero trope is the hero
having to fight some kind of reflection
of himself like iron monger in iron man
or the yellow jacket in ant-man or a lot
of marvel movies actually well shortly
after the release of the dark knight
batman was called out by batman are you
the real batman
no no no
in november 2008 variety reported that
the town of batman turkey was suing
christopher nolan and warner brothers
for using the town name without
permission there was no explanation as
to why then batman mayor hussein kalkan
was not also suing dc comics tim burton
joel schumacher or anyone else involved
in the numerous batman television shows
movies and animated series over the
years however calcan did level some
ridiculous sounding charges at the dark
knight including blaming its influence
for unsolved killings in the area
there's no word on the outcome of the
mayor's efforts though we have a tough
time believing we wouldn't have heard
something if the lawsuit went anywhere
significant we do however know that at
least one part of the country has
patched things up with the caped
crusader turkish airlines had some
significant product placement in batman
vs superman and even used bruce wayne in
an ad announcing gotham city as their
newest destination in other words
customers in the dc universe can now fly
to batman with batman
nestor carbanell who appears as the
mayor of gotham in both the dark knight
and the dark knight rises has a singular
distinction in the dark knight trilogy
like christian bale he also played
batman kind of more of a parody of
batman before the dark knight trilogy
there was the fox network's 2001 live
action version of the tick based on the
superhero spoof comic of the same name
by ben edlund among the tick's allies in
the show was batman well played by
carbonell like batman batman well
doesn't appear to have any kind of
superpowers unlike batman batman well
also doesn't seem to have any other
abilities that make him good at fighting
crime as far as we know there were no
plans for the mayor of gotham revealing
he was secretly planning to become a
caped crusader like batman and that's
probably the best choice for everybody
you may recall the scene toward the
beginning of the dark knight when bruce
wayne goes to lucious fox for upgrades
to the bat suit specifically asking to
be able to move his head you'd think it
would be a fairly small thing to ask
right if you're constantly fighting
crowds of criminals and ninjas you
should be able to look around no the
1989 version of batman couldn't do it
but this is the 21st century and super
suit technology has to have advanced a
little bit so it may surprise you to
learn that there's another very basic
function that christian bale's bat suit
didn't often allow him to do breathe
bill said that the cow was so tight that
he would have to take it off after every
couple of takes just to catch his breath
which might explain why he had such a
hard time fighting bane apparently this
was a bigger problem during the
production of batman begins than it was
on the set of the dark knight rises
though it seems that by 2012 wayne
industries finally mastered the fine art
of making clothes that won't strangle
the people wearing them
in the dark night batman's journey to
hong kong doesn't last that long but
it's arguably the most controversial
sequence of the entire film in 2007
christopher nolan denied reports that he
changed the dark knight because of hong
kong water pollution an unnamed member
of the production team had said that
originally batman was supposed to jump
out of an airplane into hong kong's
victoria harbor but that was changed
when the team tested the water and found
it to be full of contagious diseases the
following week nolan said he was the one
who changed the script but that it had
nothing to do with water pollution
quipping that as a director he wouldn't
mind dipping his actors into a little
dirty water anyway a little over a year
later warner brothers announced the dark
knight would not screen in china and
that they hadn't even submitted the film
to government sensors for consideration
the studio didn't elaborate but the
issues in question are widely believed
to revolve around the hong kong sequence
there's the simple fact that it involves
a chinese money launderer and then
there's the cameo from edison chan a
hong kong singer who at the time was
embroiled in a scandal involving
explicit photos leaked on the web
movies like batman begins and batman vs
superman dawn of justice are full of
scenes lifted directly from the pages of
dc comics here's a look at some batman
moments that will never be on the big
screen
messiah of the crimson sun if you've
ever wished the james bond flick
moonraker had starred batman instead
then boy do we have a story for you
appearing in batman annual number eight
messiah of the crimson sun involves
rachel ghoul making a giant space laser
but after commandeering a space shuttle
and engaging in some zero gravity karate
batman defeated the leader of the league
of assassins by traktor beaming him into
the laser blast considering the days of
high camp seem to be in batman's distant
past it's pretty unlikely we'll ever see
this one on screen the hunchback of the
bat cave
toys in the movies the dark knight
seemingly endless arsenal of crime
fighting equipment was either provided
by lucious fox or made down in the
batcave by alfred and batman himself
it's a pretty good answer as long as you
don't think about it too hard why nobody
down in wayne tech r d realizes they
spend an unusual amount of time sewing
up wearable hang glider capes and
bat-shaped boomerangs is anyone's guess
but honestly it actually makes way more
sense than what we got in the comics see
in the comics all this stuff came
courtesy of a hunch-backed mute
mechanical genius who lived in the bat
cave and spent his life building crap
for batman this modern-day high-tech
quasimoto was named harold allnut and
while he was essential to keeping the
bat cave operation going he almost never
got any screen time at all until he was
unceremoniously murdered the less said
about all not the better trial of the
bad witch want to know the real reason
batman and superman seem to always be at
each other's throats well one unlikely
explanation was provided in the pages of
1969's world's finest number 186 where
the man of steel and the dark knight
head back in time to find out why
real-life revolutionary war hero mad
anthony wayne looks like batman the
answer of course is that they're related
but along the way superman claims to be
a traveling actor by announcing that the
s on his chest stands for shakespeare
and then sets about convincing the good
people of 1776
that batman is a witch this might seem
out of character for superman but
there's actually a really good reason
for it he was possessed by a genie
obviously
nocturna hey remember the time batman
had a custody battle with a vampire over
who got to raise robin no
well let us introduce you to nocturna
after adopting jason todd who was robin
at the time this bloodthirsty arch
criminal then tried to convince batman
that robin could only be raised properly
if they got married a supernatural
rom-com version of kramer vs kramer with
robin stuck in the middle hey someone
call catherine heigl a christmas story
if you think the story of christmas
begins with a manger well you've clearly
never read batman the brave and the bold
number 12 which features the insane tale
of how christmas truly came to be the
story starts with earth being destroyed
and just gets weirder from there by the
end of it batman and his partner adam
strange end up literally rebuilding the
universe from within a reality altering
anti-matter stream coincidentally made
up of glowing red and green balls of
light that twists their bodies strange
ends up being stretched out and aged
with his rotund bearded appearance
imprinting on the subconscious mind of
the rebuild universe creating the idea
of santa claus and batman well batman is
actually his elf helper please make this
into a movie professor gorilla batman
has so many iconic enemies from the
joker catwoman and penguin to poison ivy
to face in the riddler that the movies
just don't seem to have room for some of
his lesser known adversaries which is
too bad because that means we'll
probably never see professor gorilla in
a movie originally appearing in the
batman manga by jiro kuata that ran in
japan's shonen ace magazine in the 1960s
professor grilla was well
he was exactly what he sounds like a
gorilla who gained genius level human
intelligence and then tried to exact
revenge on the entire human race hey if
they're going to keep making planet of
the abe's films they might as well put
batman in one robin dies at dawn if you
were looking for a great story that
dealt with the psychological trauma of
being batman you could do a lot worse
than to go back to the 1963 classic
robin dies at dawn arguably the best
batman story of the decade robin dies at
dawn shows a batman who's struggling
with the paralyzing fear that his life
as a superhero will inevitably lead only
to more death and suffering specifically
to robin's death which would cause
batman to lose his only family a second
time this crazy story begins with batman
thwarting aliens in space before
fighting criminals while wearing a
gorilla costume over his batsuit so it
has that going for it too unfortunately
for modern film fans some things are so
awesome they can only exist in the
silver age of comics sorry rainbow
batman and batbaby
dark dismal and as realistic as it gets
joker gives the batman mythos a whole
slew of updates that makes everything
feel more grounded in the real world and
in many ways more effective these are
just a few of the things that joker does
better than any other batman movie
joaquin phoenix's portrayal of arthur
fleck is more relatable than any other
clown prince we've met on the big screen
we all know what it's like to imagine
romantic lives with those who don't
reciprocate to fantasize about being
heralded in a world of fame and to be
recognized for being special we don't
thankfully all respond as fleck does
when those desires aren't fulfilled but
still getting to know arthur gives us
something we've never had with any other
joker an understanding of why he becomes
and remains the joker caesar romero's
joker of the 60s television show was
like the rest of that series antagonist
just a crook with a particular theme the
origins of heath ledger's joker are a
mystery in the dark knight and his
motivations seem to change from scene to
scene we get to meet jack napier before
he becomes joker in 1989's batman but it
doesn't help make the character more
relatable he was always kind of a huge
homicidal jerk obviously christopher
nolan and tim burton had different
priorities when making their respective
films than todd phillips did with joker
but as mcu villains like tom
hiddleston's loki and josh brolin's
thanos have taught us the more we can
relate to a super villain the more we
enjoy their portrayal
we briefly meet some of the wayne family
and joker thomas wayne is running for
mayor arthur fleck gets the opportunity
to meet his future nemesis bruce wayne
as a young boy and we even briefly meet
the butler alfred pennyworth
particularly in the case of thomas wayne
the versions we see of the characters
and joker aren't quite the saints bruce
wayne usually remembers in the various
movies
just a joke to you
out of touch and condescending
dismissive insulting and even violent
toward arthur fleck this version of
thomas wayne is refreshing and feels
genuine especially compared to other
incarnations of the guy for example
linus roach's version of thomas wayne in
2005's batman begins seems so beyond
reproach he's practically a cartoon
character he does nothing but selflessly
give to gotham offer unassailable wisdom
to his son and even in his dying breaths
worry about nothing beyond bruce's
well-being to be fair it makes sense
bruce wayne's memory of his father is
viewed through rose-colored glasses but
seeing more depth and flaws to him makes
him more than a faceless ghost fueling
batman's crusade
joker always has his followers usually
they're professional criminals like in
1989's batman in 2008's the dark knight
but in joker arthur fleck doesn't
recruit anybody at least not on purpose
after he kills three men on a subway the
news inspires the impoverished and
powerless of gotham to see him as a
symbol of resistance gotham protesters
regularly wear clown masks as a symbol
of rebellion and by the end of the film
his followers rescue him from the police
and worship him like a newborn god the
clown masked protesters of gotham are
not the mindless disposable henchmen of
the other movies which is exactly why
it's more believable they would come to
see joker as their leader they rightly
feel betrayed and forgotten by gotham
and joker offers them an empowering
alternative it may not be the healthiest
choice but it makes more sense than
hardened ex-con saying sure i'll dress
like a mime for a guy who might murder
me for a gag tomorrow
the gotham city of joker feels more like
a city situated somewhere in the real
world than any of its other big screen
incarnations the gotham of 1989's batman
and its 1992 sequel batman returns was
an imposing gothic nightmare jewel
schumacher's version in 1995's batman
forever and the 1997 hate magnet batman
and robin adds some absurd day glow to
the city making it seem that much more
cartoonish gotham like its lighter
reflection metropolis is really just new
york city with a different name and in
joker it's never been more clear that
that's exactly what it is christopher
nolan's trilogy gave us a gotham closer
to the real world than what we saw in
the burton schumacher films but joker
gets it perfect by simply giving us new
york city and calling it gotham instead
if there's one thing every version of
the joker shares it's a penchant for
violence the joker of 1989's batman
kills an unbelievable cartoonish waze
it's easy to laugh when he electrocutes
a rival mob boss and poisons gotham's
population to make them die with
gruesome forced grins just like his own
because none of it feels real
[Music]
in some cases like when he gasses an
entire museum full of patrons and
employees we don't even know if he kills
anyone or just knocks them out and it
hardly seems to matter heath ledger's
joker in 2008's the dark knight is
certainly less cartoonish than
nicholson's depiction but in many ways
his violence doesn't feel right while
ledger's performance is often intimate
and chilling the situations he's put in
often feel more like a michael bay film
than they should like when he's firing
at police cruisers with a missile
launcher from the side of an 18 wheeler
once arthur fleck turns to violence and
joker however it's a kind of violence
that not only feels more genuine to the
real world but for the joker himself
arthroflex violence is brutal and
without the hollywood sheen of big
budget action flicks it's non-stylized
and viscerally jarring
batman's secret identity is the most
closely guarded secret in the dc
universe no one must ever know well
except alfred of course and all the
robins and batgirl and superman and the
justice league and probably commissioner
gordon no villains though except for raz
al ghul and talia and catwoman persh dr
hurt well you get the idea beyond them
however no one must ever know which is
why bruce wayne has gotten to some
pretty strange extremes in order to keep
people from figuring out how he spends
us nights here are some truly bizarre
ways that batman has kept his identity a
secret the bodyguard gotham city is a
pretty dangerous town and if you're one
of its high-profile billionaires you're
bound to wind up as a target sooner or
later that's why the wayne industries
board of directors decided to hire a
bodyguard for the ceo sacha bordeaux
made her first appearance in detective
comics issue 751 taking the job as
working as a bodyguard for the last
person in the world who actually needed
one at first bruce played up his
disguise as a flaky socialite in an
attempt to make sasha so frustrated that
she'd quit but once she discovered her
secret identity everything changed since
she was still dedicated to protecting
him she insisted on joining him on his
missions as batman and he decided to
train her as a sidekick with a mask and
costume of her own despite the fact that
she performed pretty admirably in the
role her tenure ended disastrously when
bruce wayne was framed for murder and
she was arrested as an accessory she was
seemingly killed in prison and then
wound up as a cybernetic super spy
working for an intelligence agency
called checkmates you know you've got a
weird resume when batman's bodyguard
isn't the strangest thing on it
batman incorporated
the thing about batman's secret identity
is that it's not actually that hard to
figure out since everyone already knows
that he drives around gotham city in a
rocket-powered supercar once you have
that it's pretty easy to connect it to
the local billionaire whose parents were
murdered in front of him as a child in
2010 however bruce wayne used all those
obvious connections to his advantage
rather than revealing himself as batman
he instead announced that he'd been the
one financing the caped crusader using
his vast personal fortune to provide
gotham's resident vigilante with all the
grappling hooks batarangs and batmobiles
he needs and technically that's true
even if it leaves out one pretty
important detail
evil twin
after batman appeared to die in the
pages of final crisis dick grayson took
over the role but that left the question
of what to do about batman and bruce
wayne dying at the same time fortunately
they had doctor tommy elliot better
known as a supervillain hush see elliot
was so obsessed with his childhood
friend bruce wayne that he ended up
performing plastic surgery on his own
face in order to turn himself into
wayne's exact double with batman gone he
was running around pretending to be
bruce wayne depleting the wayne fortune
as fast as he could to solve the problem
batman's allies decided to let him keep
up the ruse recruiting a massive roster
of other superheroes poses employees and
assistants to keep him in line long
enough for the real batman to return
from a trip through the time stream
king batman the first
ok this is when things start to get
weird back in the 50s batman and robin
found themselves transported through a
random time warp to the planet plexius
where batman was amassed when he
accidentally became king initially
batman figured out that there was no
harm in revealing his identity to an
alien world but the criminal he and
robin had been chasing when they got hit
with the time warp was also there and
more than willing to spill the beans
when he got back to earth while this
entire problem could be avoided by just
leaving the criminal back on plexius to
face interdimensional space justice
that's a little too far from due process
even for batman instead batman and robin
decided that the best way to protect
their identities was to jump right back
into another random time warp which
fortunately wiped everyone's memories of
the entire story funny how that works
about ventriloquism
batman has done a lot of weird things to
protect a secret but the climax of the
conquest of batman's identity might be
the wildest of all it starts when
detective novelist jj jason tries to
find a bit of inspiration by solving the
most challenging mystery he can think of
figuring out who's behind batman's mask
he studies footprints analyzes a piece
of batman's cape and even gathers up a
soil sample from the bat cave to
conclusively prove that batman is bruce
wayne when he confronts bruce about it
though the result isn't what he expects
it's not what anyone expects like
several other stories like this batman
relies on a stand-in wearing his costume
to throw people off the track superman's
done it a few times for instance and
robin has a special costume of built-in
stilts just for such an occasion even
alfred did it once although for obvious
reasons that usually only works from a
distance this time though a stand-in
batman is blind and deaf and speaks to
jason via batman using ventriloquism the
fake batman also completely unnamed is
never ever mentioned again
literally nothing
at the climax of 2002's hush it's
revealed that tommy elliot wasn't
working alone instead the real foe
behind the complicated plot that
involved almost every major batman
villain was the riddler who had finally
figured out batman's secret identity
considering that the riddler is one of
batman's more enjoying foes this seems
like a pretty big deal in that same
issue however batman convinces him not
to tell anyone arguing that riddles are
worthless if everyone knows the answer
of course that conveniently ignores the
fact that it's also pretty worthless to
solve a riddle when nobody else knows
you've done it but eventually it all
worked out before too long the riddler
completely forgot batman's identity
thanks to a sharp blow to the head and a
bout of amnesia which might be batman's
true superpower the unstoppable power of
coincidence
despite their vast differences in style
and tone throughout the decades every
batman movie tends to pull from the same
handful of references and plot points
again and again to the point where you
can pretty much set your bat watch by
them
hey did you know bruce wayne's parents
were shot by a mugger in front of him
when he was a kid if you didn't it's
safe to assume that you've never seen a
movie about the dark knight because it
comes up a lot seriously we've had more
scenes of thomas and martha wayne being
gunned down in an alley over the years
than we've had batmobiles admittedly
that makes a lot of sense along with the
bats that inspired bruce to put on a
costume in order to strike beer into the
superstitious cowardly lot that is
gotham city's criminal underworld it's
the single most important thing about
his origin story still once you've seen
it happen for the fifth or sixth time it
starts to lose its impact even if each
version tries to add something new tim
burton's 1989 batman film makes it a
major plot point by casting the murderer
as the crook who would eventually become
the joker batman forever shows the
murderers multiple times as part of a
story where the riddler is stealing
memories batman begins replaces the
traditional movie theater with an opera
house and even shows us the trial of a
remorseful joe chill something that's
never really been done in another batman
story
yohana
not a day goes by then and i wish i
could take back what i did batman vs
superman dawn of justice leans into slow
motion close-ups and puts a spin on it
by having bats burst out of martha
wayne's tomb the one batman film that
doesn't feature the wayne's murders is
of course batman the movie which ties
into the 1966 adam west tv series in
fact in the show's entire 120 episode
run plus the movie the killing is only
ever mentioned once in the pilot perhaps
if there'd been anti-crime centers of
the type you now propose when my own
parents were murdered by dastardly
criminals it seems like warner brothers
finally made up for that in 2018 when
they included what might just be the
darkest and most hilarious take on the
wayne murders and the kid-friendly teen
titans go to the movies who knew robin
was that stone cold more than any other
superhero batman has an incredible
roster of compelling villains with a
deep bench that goes from worldwide
threats like raza ghoul to sinister
nuisances like the riddler and even
classic anti-heroes like catwoman who
had become main characters worthy of a
spotlight in their own right they're the
best bad guys in comics as a result the
batman movies are always eager to
introduce a new villain and almost all
of them make sure to dive into their
origin stories
jack is dead my friend
you can call me
joker the big exception is of course
batman 66 where all four baddies are
already well-known arch criminals just
like they are on the show the rest of
them however go hard at origins batman
89 doesn't just show us the joker going
into a bat of acid it gives us his
complete backstory as the underling of a
mob boss complete with its own web of
double crosses
you
are my number one guy
batman returns does even more not only
do we see selena kyle's breakdown and
reemergence as catwoman we also get the
penguin's literal life story from
infancy to death batman begins shows us
the scarecrow's transition from weirdo
doctor to full-on super villain and
batman and robin that movie actually
does this four times giving us the
origin of poison ivy a backstory from mr
freeze that explains why he looks like a
bodybuilder a beginning for bane and if
you want to get technical about it it
even has an origin story for jason
woodru the fluoronic man it's easy to
point to the dark knight as a movie that
studiously avoids giving its major
villain a backstory as the joker gives a
few conflicting versions of his past to
preserve his mystery instead it's a film
focused on the origin of super villainy
itself in addition to giving us a full
origin for two-face it also shows the
joker's first reign of terror in gotham
city which ends up being the end of
traditional organized crime and a
beginning for costume super criminals
for decades alfred pennyworth was
batman's loyal and somewhat bumbling
butler with a few notable exceptions
however the movies tend to avoid
introducing robin and alfred became one
of the only people that batman can speak
to casually as a result he became a
sarcastic comedic foil for the very
serious dark knight the clearest example
of this is probably michael kane's
betrayal of alfred and the dark knight
trilogy who seems to delight in throwing
shade at batman and pretty much everyone
else did you get mauled by a tiger it
was a dog huh it was a big dog
it's definitely present across all
versions though the jeremy irons version
from batman vs superman is the only
counterbalance to the movie's otherwise
all-consuming grimness michael goff's
alfred revels in dunking on the caped
crusader by telling embarrassing
childhood stories about bruce wayne to
his potential girlfriend come on man let
the guy have a couple of secrets
batman's identity is one of his most
important secrets bruce wayne is after
all a very public figure whose home
address is pretty easy to figure out so
if his enemies ever discovered exactly
who was underneath that mask he'd be in
a whole lot of trouble and there's also
the fact that being a vigilante is
technically extremely illegal no matter
how many custom-made spotlights you
mount on top of the police station and
yet every time batman hits the silver
screen the whole secret part of his
identity goes right out the window the
dark knight trilogy might actually be
the most egregious in this regard razo
ghoul knew from the very beginning
rachel dawes figures it out thanks to
batman repeating a familiar phrase and
even some random dude who works at wayne
enterprises notices that batman's
exclusively using stuff that should be
down in the warehouse in batman 89
alfred just walks vicki vale down to the
bat cave one afternoon which not only
blows his secret identity but also
forces her to see the unforgettable
sight to batman wearing mom jeans in
batman forever the riddler learns it by
literally stealing bruce wayne's
memories and then using the information
to blow up the batcave justice league
even features a scene where the
extremely famous bruce wayne is just
hanging out in public with aquaman
talking about being batman all of that
can be forgiven though because it also
gives us the single greatest moment of
batman returns and one of the best
scenes in any batman movie when batman
pulls off his mask to make a heart belt
plea to catwoman max shrek played by
christopher walken reacts the way most
of us would in that moment why you
dressed up like batman because he is
batman you [ __ ]
[Music]
with all the chaos in gotham city it
isn't shocking that a few mistakes have
been made by the filmmakers who've
brought the dark knight to the big
screen so what are some of the biggest
mistakes lurking in the batman movies
caught red-handed when the joker orders
his cronies to destroy everything in
gotham's museum during tim burton's
batman one henchman gleefully smacks a
bunch of red hand prints all over a
painting but in the very next frame the
graffiti has magically disappeared and
he's back to defacing a painting from
earlier
mums everywhere would probably like to
know where he got those washable paints
joker's bloody chin
moments before he plummets from a
helicopter the joker is visibly bloody
from his mouth to his chin and although
the fall kills him a close-up shot
reveals it somehow did miracles for his
beauty regimen
selena's rearranging kitchen
single lady selena kyle is in such a
rush when she runs out of her apartment
that she forgets to put the milk back in
the fridge
but when she returns after her little
accident the carton is nowhere to be
seen and the dishes in the drying rack
are moved around too
did her cats tidy up or did the milk
have an even weirder night than she did
that's not the only weird thing going on
in her apartment soon after the scene
selena starts to assemble her catwoman
costume brandishing a pair of blue
scissors
or are they pink
maybe it's maybelline
as batman prepares to reveal his
identity to catwoman in batman returns
he's seen with his usual dark eye makeup
surrounding his eyes but after a quick
cutaway
it's suddenly gone this is because he's
about to remove his mask and apparently
it was about 25 years too early for this
look
ivy's vanishing gloves batman and robin
from
1997 it had a lot of problems and simple
continuity was one of them seated in the
backseat of a limousine driven by bane
poison ivy is clearly wearing black
gloves when she begins to put on a wig
however in the next shot her gloves are
gone just another victim of joel
schumacher's madness
the spiked bracelets that wasn't the
only time poison ivy's arms with a
victim of bad continuity she's wearing
thin leaflet gloves when she first
welcomes robin into her lair but when
she angrily pushes him into a gross
swimming pool she's suddenly wearing
spiky rubber bracelets the transporting
gun in batman begins bruce wayne is
waiting at the courthouse to shoot joe
chill the man who killed his parents a
female assassin runs up and pushes a
pistol up against the criminal's chest
instead when she shoots a split second
later she's holding the gun at least a
foot away not even batman moves that
fast
where are you
here
joker's fast hands during the iconic
interrogation scene in the dark knight
the joker and batman tangle while the
gotham city police department looks on
but it seems like they got a little more
tangled than anyone expected as batman
holds joker up against a wall joker
holds onto batman's arms with a chin up
grip but when the camera angle changes
the clown prince is doing a pull-up
instead before his hands quickly return
to their first position the botched
headline
gotham's copy editors
should probably get fired for this one
or at least the props department in the
dark knight rises bruce wayne stumbles
upon a newspaper headline while
conducting some online research about
the cat burglar in town where the word
heist is clearly misspelled i guess it
could have been worse
despite the declining success of the
batman film franchise in the 90s warner
brothers knew that in the right hands
the character was still a gold mine even
though two-time batman director joel
schumacher was interested in making
another installment the studio wanted to
start fresh that's how darren aronofsky
got a deal to pin a screenplay with
frank miller to adapt miller's comic
batman year one that story arc was
eventually made as an animated film but
aronofsky and miller's screenplay never
got developed here's why we never got to
see it
a darker night
the year one comic follows bruce wayne's
return to gotham after 12 years of
travel and training he befriends a young
jim gordon and the two take down
gangsters within carmine falcone's mob
organization despite citing year one as
their inspiration aronofsky and miller
changed a lot of aspects of the comic
for the screenplay such as making young
bruce wayne live as a bum while learning
how to fight crime from books the big
takeaway according to miller was that
the script just strayed too far from the
traditional batman storylines and
included elements that took the film in
some dark directions considering pg-13
is as far as warner brothers has ever
gone with batman this new take on batman
was just too far from family friendly
bait and switch
darren aronofsky later admitted that he
was never particularly interested in
making a batman movie he was trying to
make a different movie and he saw year
one as a way to get the studio behind
his indie effort he explained it was a
kind of bait and switch strategy i was
working on requiem for a dream and i got
a phone call that warner brothers wanted
to talk about batman at the time i had
this idea for a film called the fountain
which i knew was gonna be this big movie
my theory was if i can write this batman
film and they can perceive me as a
writer for it then maybe they let me go
ahead even though the batman movie never
materialized warner brothers did finally
give him funding to make the fountain in
2006 so at least some good came out of
the whole thing
tough cast
according to the book tales from
development hell aronofsky's original
pitch is what intrigued warner brothers
enough to give him a crack at the caped
crusader aronofsky's idea was to take
the movie in a gritty realistic
direction and his main choice for the
dark gritty hero clint eastwood you've
got to ask yourself one question do i
feel lucky
well do you punk
dirty harry in a bad suit sounds like a
great idea but that casting decision
didn't pan out ironofsky then settled on
year one as his source material and
according to a 2017 yahoo interview he
wanted to cast joaquin phoenix as the
younger bruce wayne neither of his
casting choices seemed to give warner
brothers much confidence and aronofsky
later suggested that the entire concept
might have just been too far ahead of
its time
inexperienced
with only robocop 2 and robocop 3 as
screenwriting credits at this point
frank miller admitted he had a lot to
learn about the movie business he
explained the whole process was one of
discovery for me i had to figure out
what they wanted normally somebody like
me if you say you want to make a movie
i'll come up with something that will be
12 hours long and cost 1 billion dollars
to make
premature prequel
even without the gritty r-rated tone the
two filmmakers wanted for year one
there's a chance the movie would have
eventually been canned anyway prequels
and spin-offs may be a big market now
but in 1999 most movie studios preferred
to bank on sequels to keep a franchise
going so when aronofsky and miller
decided to wipe out the entire batman
film timeline to start fresh with year
one the studio may have been hesitant
ultimately the possibility of new toys
and merchandise might have been the
deciding factor in warner brothers
agreeing to start working on the film
although that angle didn't pan out
either
toy bust
after giving warner brothers his and
aronofsky's script miller quickly
realized that batman year one probably
wasn't going to pan out describing how
the studio reacted he said i think i
heard a shriek of horror at first they
were shocked at how bold it was in other
words it wasn't going to be a movie that
sold a lot of toys miller spelled it out
clearly when he recalled being told that
the project wasn't moving forward the
executive wanted to do a batman he could
take his kids to and this wasn't that it
didn't have the toys in it who defends
this city batman and robin and that's
ultimately what sunkier won warner
brothers didn't feel like it was the
right fit for burger king tie-in that's
too bad because it definitely sounds
like the best batman film we never saw
[Music]
from the hero's origins to centuries of
injustice the dark knight trilogy
possesses a gritty yet fascinating world
here we'll explore the history of bruce
wayne and his more realistic rogues
gallery and how three films made us
believe a man could you know not fly but
do wingsuit stuff
in a chaotic world it can be comforting
to imagine that there's a singular force
behind history's most horrifying events
organizations so powerful and secretive
that they can hide in plain sight while
pulling the metaphorical strings of a
society in the dark knight trilogy those
theories would be entirely well founded
since an enigmatic group known as the
league of shadows has been molding
civilization for more than a thousand
years their theory is that when a great
nation becomes too large and decadent it
needs to be purged like an overgrown
forest
secrecy is their calling card but we're
given a few glimpses of the league's
actions over the centuries through their
leader raz al ghul we sacked rome loaded
trade ships with plague rats burned
london to the ground
his former claim likely refers to the
attack on the roman former capital in
410 a.d by the visigoths an event that
led in part to the fall of the roman
empire but ra's al ghul further implies
that the league retained power through
the 14th and 17th centuries
around the early to mid 80s a young raz
algol then a mercenary for hire falls in
love with the daughter of a powerful
warlord the warlord orders that raz is
to be thrown into an infamous prison
known only as the pit a deep hole in an
unnamed but ancient country
the warlord's daughter arranges to take
the place of raz in exchange for his
freedom never letting raz or her father
know a few months later also without
raz's knowledge he gives birth to his
child a girl named talia
the girl's mother is attacked and killed
by fellow inmates a short time later and
talia falls under the protection of bane
a man who's spent his entire life in the
pit as a young girl talia attains a
legendary status among the pit's
prisoners when she becomes the first
inmate to successfully escape while she
climbs to freedom bane holds back the
other enraged prisoners and is
gruesomely disfigured in the process
talia tracks down her father now a high
level figure in the league of shadows
and he goes to the pit executing the
people responsible for his lover's death
and extracting bane recruiting him for
the league and treating his injuries
with the use of a mask that continually
doses him with pain suppressants
far away from the pit on the other side
of the world the league of shadows plot
to cause an economic collapse in gotham
is thrown off by an unforeseen factor
the rise of philanthropist power couple
thomas and martha wayne thomas a
celebrated surgeon is also the chairman
of wayne enterprises a technology and
real estate development company as well
as the head of the charitable wayne
foundation i leave the running of our
company a much better man
better wow
more interested man thomas and martha
invest heavily in improving gotham
funding the construction of an elevated
train system suspiciously similar to
chicago's l
ironically thomas and martha succeed in
pulling gotham out of its depression but
only in their deaths
the two are shot and killed in a mugging
by a low-level criminal joe chill the
city's elite are inspired into action
helping to clean up gotham and create a
better if imperfect place to live little
knowing that this will inspire further
more insidious actions by the league
joe chill is hastily arrested for the
deaths of thomas and martha wayne and he
spends roughly a decade behind bars
while there he shares a cell with mob
boss carmine falcone and manages to
glean information on his criminal
activities and that's when chill decides
to become a stool pigeon exchanging
testimony about the gangster for parole
bruce wayne attends chill's hearing with
a small revolver in his pocket intending
to kill the man who killed his family
unbeknownst to wayne falcone has bribed
the judge moving chill's hearing into a
public space so that one of falcone's
assassins can get to chill before bruce
is able to after a meeting with falcone
and a slap heavy chewing out from rachel
bruce realizes that he's ill-equipped to
stop crime in any meaningful way or
protect the people he loves
now you think
because your mommy and your daddy got
shot you know about the ugly side of
life but you don't burning his
identification bruce goes off the grid
traveling the world in search of meaning
understanding and mentorship he gets
that in bhutan where he's offered
membership in the league of shadows
told that the league is a force for
order the world's greatest detective
doesn't realize that a group of
explosive enthusiast ninjas might be in
the business of killing people until his
initiation ceremony during which he's
told to take the life of a man who's
killed his neighbors expressing a
philosophy of non-lethal violence bruce
blows up the league's compound with
everyone still inside only managing to
save his mentor who he leaves in the
care of a local villager
bruce returns to gotham where he
befriends experimental weapons designer
lucius fox an employee of wayne
enterprises who outfits him with
equipment to combat the city's criminal
element what's that
another tumblr
or you wouldn't be interested in that
creating the batman persona and
initiating an uneasy partnership with
detective james gordon bruce stops a
fresh league of shadows plot to release
a hallucinogenic neurotoxin developed by
local psychiatrist jonathan crane
somewhere around this point bruce wayne
visits an orphanage funded by the wayne
foundation where a young kid named robin
john blake is living an angry child
blake recognizes something in wayne
anger masked behind a smile a lot of
people know what it feels like
do they
be angry
in your bones
blake feels a kinship with wayne looking
up to him as a hero figure he deduces
that wayne is probably batman and out of
either a sense of respect or an
understanding of what bat snitches get
doesn't tell anyone blake will grow up
and move out of the boy's home
eventually becoming one of the rare
incorruptable cops on gotham city's
payroll there he'll partner with james
gordon and become entangled in batman's
world of gritty animal-based vigilantism
at the end of batman begins gordon
informs batman that his wearing a mask
and generally making a scene has led to
escalation from the city's criminal
element with one particularly troubling
new figure committing a series of crimes
and leaving behind a joker playing card
each time
nine months later the man calling
himself the joker is still at large
plus at a lower rung on the calamity
ladder jonathan crane has fully adopted
his scarecrow persona and is somehow
making a living selling recreational
fear gas presumably thanks to the fact
that teenagers will try anything these
days with public safety at the forefront
of the political landscape a new
district attorney is elected harvey dent
a handsome optimist who gives a recently
promoted lieutenant gordon the leeway he
needs to continue collaborating with
batman
bruce keeps a watchful eye on the new
d.a in part because of the lawyer's
romantic involvement with rachel as the
joker's crime spree picks up momentum
bruce decides to focus his efforts on
stopping the city's organized crime
rings ironically not seeing the threat
inherent in a single exceptional
dramatic symbol his war on the mob opens
up gotham's underworld leaving it
vulnerable to the forces of chaos do i
really look like a guy with a plan
with batman's attention divided joker
takes control of gotham's organized
crime kills a judge and the police
commissioner and reframes the public's
perception of batman during his reign of
terror joker kidnaps rachel and harvey
killing the former and mutilating the
latter burning off half his face and
driving him into the depths of vengeful
homicidal madness as a result of these
actions batman pulls his emergency cord
a high-tech surveillance system that
creates a three-dimensional sonar map in
real time by employing the use of every
cell phone in the city in the end the
joker is captured but harvey's revenge
ride concludes when he kidnaps gordon's
family and holds them at gunpoint
batman tackles dent off of a ledge
killing him and agrees to take the blame
for the disgraced da's string of crimes
he rides into the night a wanted
fugitive and harvey's death becomes the
precipitating event in the enactment of
a series of laws that enable the police
to go even tougher on crime suspending
their civil liberties in the name of law
and order
during batman's self-imposed exile bruce
wayne works to better gotham city in
ways that rely more on working towards
meeting the needs of its citizens by
creating a sustainable future and less
on punching guys who steal stereos
he helps to fund an exciting clean
energy project but his sense of moral
obligation forces him to shutter the
experiment after it's revealed that the
machine at the center of things could
with a little light tweaking be turned
into a nuclear bomb after that nobody
sees or hears from bruce wayne for three
years
but you're not living you're just
waiting hoping for things to go bad
again the tough on crime laws inspired
by the death of harvey dent called the
dent act have allowed now commissioner
gordon to wipe crime off the streets of
gotham but at a great cost to his
conscience he's drafted a letter of
resignation admitting to his and
batman's ruse
he keeps the letter close but stays on
the force mentoring a young officer john
blake meanwhile overseas the league of
shadows has been reformed thanks to two
leaders talia algul and bane after years
of work the two begin enacting a plan to
finish what their predecessors started
and destroy gotham
john daggett a crooked construction
company owner brings bane to the united
states in the hopes of taking over wayne
enterprises his plan involves a stock
market raid and shady business dealings
after first employing bane to help
secure diamond mining rights in africa
of course a merry series of mishaps
occur daggett is killed by bane who's
been using the businessman's
construction firms to plant explosives
all over gotham in order to protect
wayne enterprises from a hostile
takeover bruce hands control of his
company to fellow clean energy
enthusiast miranda tate who he doesn't
yet realize is in league with the league
bruce brings the batman persona out of
retirement and with the help of a live
jewel thief tracks bane to gotham sewers
however selena kyle the jewel thief was
working with bane who's waiting for
batman
he lays a thick layer of the smackdown
on bats then has him imprisoned in the
pit where he's tortured with a tv view
of the destruction of his beloved city
with gotham's dark knight out of the way
bane closes off all land entrances to
the city blowing up bridges and tunnels
now we come here not as conquerors
but as liberators to return control of
this city to the people
he then drops the truth on the public
harvey dent was a killer the dent act
was unjust and bane has turned wayne
enterprise's clean energy project into a
bomb which will explode when an unknown
gothamite presses the button the bomb
will explode regardless of whether or
not it's triggered but bane uses the
chaos to impose martial law releasing
the criminals in black gate prison and
employing batman's stolen armory of
vehicles for around six months gotham is
a military state where any crime is
punishable by execution bruce meanwhile
is still recovering from his injuries he
learns about the prison's history and
makes several attempts to escape the pit
finally sticking the landing the third
time through unseen means and with no
money or resources he returns to the
united states and infiltrates gotham's
blockade back in the city he loves
batman reaches out to the jewel thief
who betrayed him before because he has a
good feeling about her
sometimes in a story about a guy who
fights crime with animal-shaped
boomerangs you just have to suspend your
disbelief impossible
with the help of the city's surviving
police force batman and catwoman go to
war with bane
in yet another twist it's revealed that
bane was never in charge of the league
of shadows he was the darth vader to the
emperor palpatine that is miranda tate
aka talia al ghul
talia takes off to protect the bomb
while catwoman takes the opening and
explodes bane with a shot from the bat
pod she has on loan together the heroes
chase down talia and bruce forces her
truck off the road killing her and
really making the audience look back at
all those car crashes he's caused over
the course of the trilogy with a more
skeptical eye towards his no killing
policy in a final act of bravery batman
latches the bomb to his snazzy
helicopter making sure we all know that
the autopilot is on the fritz and that
this is the only way
he flies the explosive out over open
water and with a tug at our heartstrings
blows right up
or does he
a number of things change in the months
following the siege of gotham the
public's trust in batman is restored
enough so that a statue of the caped
crusader is commissioned bruce wayne is
pronounced dead and a token funeral is
held sparsely attended by alfred john
blake lucius fox and james gordon who
after years of cooperation finally
pieces together that batman and the only
guy in the city who could afford a
custom vtol aircraft might be one in the
same person the wayne fortune is left to
alfred wayne manor is converted into a
home for orphans and at-risk kids john
blake recently having left the police
force over concerns with its
effectiveness is left with instructions
on how to enter the bat cave
this is where we learn his first name is
robin implying that he will soon possess
the least effective secret identity in
superhero history
and then lucius discovers that the
aircraft bruce flew into that long good
night actually had its autopilot
functions repaired some time later
alfred goes to get lunch at an italian
cafe that he told bruce about
there he sees bruce and selena enjoying
a meal is it a dream the wishful
imaginings of an old man or did batman
really escape gotham to start a new life
with catwoman
well since we don't see any inception
style top spinning we're going to assume
that the dark knight trilogy concludes
with a happy ending
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite stuff are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]